everyone and welcome to reality check
you know it's almost that time of year
again a new Call of Duty is nearly upon
us love or hate the series though there
is no denying that the annual Cod
arrival has cemented itself as an
inescapable part of the yearly games
calendar now this time around the series
is going all futuristic sci-fi with Call
of Duty advanced warfare the game is
said to feature a ton of super cool
advanced battle Hardware far beyond the
real-life scientific cutting-edge sci-fi
tech like exoskeletons jetpacks and
Kevin Spacey but hold on a minute
perhaps we're not that far from this
technology so let's investigate exactly
how close are we to the science fiction
of Call of Duty advanced warfare
[Music]
if you haven't seen the latest power
changes everything trailer then I highly
recommend that you go and take a look
granted it's pretty chock-full of
recycled trailer tropes such as shot
screaming oh my god the car real our new
gen faces look fortuitous use of slow-mo
and superlative puts from websites that
nobody in the right mind would ever good
oh wait that one's pretty good
but alongside all of that there is some
really exciting technology check it out
every time we get a shot of one of the
soldier chaps we can clearly see that
they are wearing exoskeletons now while
their overall kit does look pretty
chunky it's not an all encasing armor
plated battle suit although that type of
tech does feature further on in the
trailer
in fact if you want to know more about
the science of mech suits like these
take a look at the reality check episode
on the science of titanfall back to our
average advanced warfare soldiers
featured in the trailer now they appear
to be equipped with one of the more
subtle supportive frames the job of
these exoskeletons is quite simple to
enable personnel to do more with less
carry more weapons armor and supplies
while exerting less efforts and burning
fewer calories you know what this type
of tech actually exists right now behold
Hulk or human Universal load carrier in
development by Lockheed Martin this
hydraulic powered contraption really
looks a heck of a lot like the tech in
Call of Duty and perhaps a bit bulkier
Hulk adds an artificial spine hips legs
and arm to a soldier's squishy
biological frame the Machine extremities
powered by standard lithium ion battery
Tec redistribute and transfer up to 200
pounds of weight down to the ground and
off the operators body there's actually
a newer model now than the one shown in
this three-year-old promo video it's
lighter and can allegedly run for up to
eight hours on battery power alone as
opposed to the 60 minute runtime of this
guy pretty impressive so why aren't
soldiers using these exoskeletons today
or are they and we just don't know
well back in 2012 Lockheed Martin said
that Hulk could be in deployment in war
zones
as early as the end of that year but I
can't find any confirmation on whether
or not that actually happened but you
know what Hulk isn't the only sexy
exosuit in town
say hello to Fortis also from the chaps
in Ch a pets at Lockheed Martin now this
is a more scaled down version of Hulk
focusing on mobility and keeping it
lightweight in fact at a measly thirty
pounds it weighs at least 20 pounds
lighter than Hulk it's also primarily
designed for industrial use rather than
combat and can support up to 36 pounds
of tools attached to the front our early
tests have proved really promising and
have demonstrated that the exoskeleton
can increase productivity of workers
anywhere from two to twenty-seven times
depending on the job in hand now if you
ask me I think the exoskeleton in the
trailer looks a bit like a love child
between these two designs lightweight
and elegant but also damn powerful now
another thing we'll soldiers in Call of
Duty advanced warfare seem to be kitted
out with our jetpacks these shoot the
wearer up into the air at a moment's
notice helping to avoid enemy fire or as
a way of gaining the tactical advantage
our jetpacks are very real pieces of kit
but they tend to be a bit big for use in
combat situations case in point the
Martin jetpack now don't get me wrong
it's pretty awesome but not only would
it make for an enormous target in a
firefight it's also not exactly very
maneuverable and to be honest two packs
of Call of Duty advanced warfare do
appear to be more like jump packs
designed for short blasts rather than
sustained flight now these also exist in
real life as well but they are generally
one-time only use type of kit tricky to
control in flight and also far from
stable as they usually generate their
lift from a rapid breakdown of hydrogen
peroxide which can be a tad explosive
but don't despair just yet the reality
of soldiers being equipped with jetpacks
might be closer than you think
check out this little contraption from
the Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency or DARPA and the folks at the
University of Arizona's human machine
integration lab
so what we've done is we've reduced the
amount of force we're not able to fly
with our jet pack but we have
instantaneous thrust and we can pretty
much trigger it to allow you know for
faster movements agile motions and so
forth very interesting but how good are
they well early tests have showed
significant improvements in running lap
times over a mile test athlete alexander
chapman shaved 18 seconds of his
original mile time of 5 minutes 20
seconds by using the jetpack now ok 18
seconds may not sound groundbreaking but
when you consider that that second time
around he was wearing an 11 pound
backpack it is still encouraging now the
ultimate goal is to enable any wear of
the device of decent fitness to be able
to run a four-minute mile it's not hard
to imagine how this ability to have an
instantaneous speed boost on the
battlefield could make the difference
between life and death
so what did you make of this week's
episode and the technology discussed how
long do you think it will be until or
real-life soldiers are kitted out with
exoskeletons and jump packs and would
you like to see me do a part 2 on all
the technology that we're seeing in Call
of Duty advanced warfare let me know in
the comments down below or by reaching
out to me on Twitter at cam for us Rob
now next week on reality check you'll
want to come back because we're doing a
special all about Assassin's Creed unity
we'll see you then
you
[Music]